las personas que tienen afecciones
pulmonares como el asma o la eps a
menudo toman sus medicamentos mediante
el uso de un dispositivo manual llamado
inhalador de dosis medidas md y por sus
siglas en inglés
un inhalador de dosis medidas rocía el
medicamento por la boca para que pueda
llegar a las vías respiratorias si su
inhalador no se usa de la manera
correcta es posible que parte del
medicamento no entra en la boca o que
quede en la parte posterior de ésta en
todo caso es posible que no llegue a las
vías respiratorias donde se necesita
este vídeo le mostrará los pasos
generales para usar un inhalador de
manera correcta
es importante seguir las instrucciones
que trae su inhalador de dosis medidas
un inhalador de dosis medidas tiene tres
partes principales la tapa de la
boquilla el manguito de plástico con
boquilla y el contenedor del medicamento
antes de usar el inhalador de dosis
medidas retire la tapa de la boquilla y
agite el inhalador
si esta es la primera vez que usa su
inhalador o si no lo ha usado durante un
tiempo tendrá que llevarlo
lea las instrucciones para saber cómo y
cuándo hacer esto con su inhalador ya
que puede variar según el tipo de
inhalador y medicamento
cuando esté listo para usar el inhalador
póngase de pie o siéntese derecho
respire hondo y exhale completamente
para vaciar los pulmones
después de agitar el inhalador coloque
la boquilla en la boca y cierre los
labios sobre ella para formar un sello
hermético
al inhalar aire cuando respira por la
boca presione firmemente en la parte
superior del inhalador para liberar una
bocanada de medicamento
continúa respirando lentamente por la
boca durante 3 a 5 segundos hasta que
los pulmones estén completamente llenos
se recomienda contener la respiración
contando aproximadamente hasta 10
finalmente exhale lentamente por la boca
si su dosis de medicamentos requiere dos
inhalaciones puede que tenga que esperar
antes de tomar la segunda inhalación
siga las instrucciones que trae su
inhalador para saber cuánto deberá
esperar entre inhalaciones
después de usar un inhalador de
esteroides enjuagues de la boca con agua
y escupa la
es importante mantener el inhalador
limpio para que funcione correctamente
lea las instrucciones de su inhalador
para ver la manera correcta de limpiarlo
el uso adecuado del inhalador de dosis
medidas puede ayudarle a controlar los
síntomas de su afección pulmonar si
tiene preguntas sobre el uso de su
inhalador hablé con su proveedor de
atención médica o farmacéutico pídales
que observen cómo usa su inhalador para
ver si lo está usando correctamente